bonsoir et bienvenue à tous et avant de
développer ces titres une fois n'est pas
coutume nous avons voulu ouvrir ce
journal par des images qu'on voit
rarement et qui incarne l'espoir
l'espoir d'une prévention qui fait son
chemin contre le sida
en cette journée mondiale de lutte
contre la maladie l'onu souligne que le
nombre de nouveaux cas recul en afrique
grâce à cette prévention et voici l'une
des actions les moins connus mais dont
l'efficacité est désormais incontesté la
circoncision reportage en afrique du sud
sur ces petits gestes qui peuvent tout
changer dominique derda frédéric rang qu
il n'emmène pas bien large ces jeunes
sud africains ils ont beau se serrer les
coudes
aucun d'entre eux n'est jamais passée
par là il n'ya donc personne pour
rassurer son voisin tout ce matin sont
venus se faire circoncire lavoine
scrabble ils vont me couper 28 avec des
ciseaux alors oui j'ai peur je suis un
peu inquiet mais pas trop je veux le
faire si t'es pas circoncis tu peux plus
facilement être infecté par une femme
ce décret et là c'est plus sûr il faut
oui aujourd'hui ils sont une vingtaine
âgés de 15 à 30 ou 35 ans et l'été en
afrique du sud l'hiver ils sont plus
nombreux encore
l'opération se pratique sous anesthésie
locale
le seul moment où ça fait un peu mal
ensuite il paraît qu'on ne sent plus
rien l'association qui effectue à la
chaîne c'est circoncision s'appelle baup
est loupé les dans la langue locale
ça veut dire la santé d'abord en un
quart d'heure à peine tout est terminé
elle est depuis que notre centre a
ouvert ses portes en janvier 2008
je crois que nous avons dû pratiquer aux
environs de 18 me circoncision à
l'origine de ce programme le professeur
bertrand auvert longtemps il a dû
batailler pour convaincre que la
circoncision est l une des armes les
plus efficaces et les moins chers pour
lutter contre la transmission du virus
aujourd'hui le doute n'est plus permis
nos études ont montré que la réduction
de la transmission du vih de la femme un
homme du à la circoncision était de 60%
mais aussi 7 circoncision réduit la
transmission du papillomavirus qui est
la cause principale et cancer du col de
l'utérus mais aussi d'une chirurgie leur
pérennité
quand ils font campagne dans les
townships des environs les animateurs de
baup est loupé l'est se garde bien de
prétendre que la circoncision est le
remède miracle qu'il n'y a plus aucun
risque
ils insistent au contraire sur la
nécessité absolue de continuer à se
protéger value casif on leur explique
qu'ils doivent toujours mettre des
préservatifs mais qu' elle se tient à
préserver type se déchirent
bien grâce à la circoncision le risque
qu'ils soient contaminés est beaucoup
moins élevé il n'y a pas encore en
afrique du sud de programme national de
promotion la circoncision mais ça ne
saurait tarder
en attendant un vaccin qui ne vient
toujours pas tout est bon pour faire
reculer l'épidémie